the mullah report exonerates President
Trump on collusion lets him off the hook
on obstruction and generally melts down
the entire media I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show o day of days it
finally arrived over the weekend the
summary from Attorney General bar about
the Muller report we'll get into all of
that in just one second first let's talk
about how you stay fit so I'll tell you
this my wife does not have time to go to
the gym
I mean she's working incredibly long
hours because as you know she is a
doctor and that means that at night we
work out together how do we work out
well we use a system called open fit
open fit takes all the complexity out of
losing weight and getting fit it's a
brand new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your living or living room in
as little as 10 minutes a day it really
is spectacular everybody's bodies are
different open fit gets that which is
why it is personalized to your needs
with custom tailored original content
they've got amazing trainers and classes
they've got classes led by some of the
most effective and engaging trainers in
the world you can sculpt your body with
Andrea Roger she's founder of the
worldwide sensation extend bar a or you
can get in crazy good shape with Hunter
McIntyre named by Sports Illustrated is
one of the top 50 fittest athletes it is
super simple because you can workout on
your schedule you can simply do it on
demand you can access it anywhere
anytime so when I'm on the road I use
open fit as well and there are results
you can see can lose up to 15 pounds in
the first 30 days if you really go for
it flatten those abs shape your body
look and feel great
I love open fit I used some of it over
the weekend myself and again my wife's
been using it all the time it's really
fantastic open fit changes the way you
workout with my coach Shapiro you can
join me on a fitness journey
personalized for you again use coach
Shapiro and start using open fit for
your journey to a healthier life right
now during the open fat 30-day challenge
my listeners get a special extended
30-day free trial so you can try it
right now or you can lose up to 15
pounds in 30 days when you text Shapiro
to 30 30 30 you will get full access to
open fit totally free again just extra
pro2 30 30 30 and give it a try for an
extended 30-day free trial that's
awesome check out open fit get in shape
it's really I can't recommend it more
highly
okay so last Friday after my show the
Muller report essentially broke in the
media at least the top line of the
Muller report broke in the media no new
indictments and then over the weekend we
found out
Attorney General bar William bar that
not only would there be no indictments
there was no evidence of collusion and
that President Trump was not going to be
indicted on obstruction that there was
no clear evidence of obstruction we're
gonna get to bars
report in just one second but first I
need to remind you where we came from
how we got here because it's been two
long years there like the old lady at
the end of Titanic it's been 84 years
it's been two long years since we
started this whole debacle with the
claim that President Trump was in
cahoots with the Russians was working
hand in glove with Vladimir Putin in
order to skew the results of the 2016
election that he and his campaign had
been working with Putin in order to
attack the DNC reveal the emails come
after Hillary Clinton and generally
destroy electoral democracy in the
United States and this was the
constantly repeated refrain for two
years
CNN ran with this for two years MSNBC
ran with this for two years the
Washington Post and The New York Times
and everybody ran with this the
Democrats made it their talking point
was their chief talking point the
president Trump was not actually the
legitimate President of the United
States instead he had been installed by
Russian Fiat from nefarious means
Hillary Clinton was the actual real
president of the United States so here
is just a quick montage of some of the
members of the media and Democrats
claiming that President Trump was guilty
of the gravest sort of treason
there are indictments in this
president's future
that's a bombshell the bomb show this
bombshell dropped the bombshell
bombshell accusation bombshell
accusations and at that point we are in
high crimes that misdemeanor and we are
in impeachment
right this president needs to be
impeached impeachment is the remedy I
mean the president can't do his remedy
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question I think he's feeling the
noose around his neck
the noose is tightening and I think
they're shocked that the noose is
tightening he may be the first president
in quite some time to face the real
prospect of jail time well I think they
were all going to end up together in
prison and maybe that's okay it's
legitimately virtually every major
member of MSNBC and CNN that was Adam
Schiff of course you heard Joy Behar at
the very end and this was the
wisdom hey there's the conventional
wisdom was that President Trump was
going to do jail time it's very least
you'd be impeached that the evidence
would come out people were going nuts
over all of this stuff I mean for
goodness sake the people were selling
votive candles of robert muller online
on etsy like worship candles of robert
muller SNL did an entire number where
they say at Christmas time called all I
want for Christmas is you and it was a
picture of Bob Muller in the background
Bob Muller was the deus ex machina Bob
Muller was the apocalypse come to earth
Bob Muller was final justice come for
president Trump that's what that was
their case this is where they were going
and you had high-ranking members of US
intelligence people like John Brennan
the former head of the CIA under Obama
who was there while all of this was
going on in 2016
yeah John Brennan on MSNBC two weeks ago
suggesting that President Trump was
headed for jail parties the day that the
grand jury indictments come down and
also this Friday is better than next
Friday because next Friday is the 15th
of March which is the Ides of March and
I don't think Robert Muller will want to
have that dramatic flair of the Ides of
March when he is going to be delivering
what I think are going to be his
indictments the final indictments as
well as the report that he gives the
Attorney General so if anybody from the
Trump family an extended family is going
to be indicted it would be in the final
act of molars investigation okay so this
was this was John Brennan okay remember
the former head of the CIA and it was a
mess of former intelligence heads saying
this sort of stuff it was Andrew McCabe
the ousted former acting FBI director
who was fired for lying to the FBI
you'll recall he lost his pension
because he was lying to the FBI about
leaking to the media and just in the
last few weeks he suggested that
President Trump it was quite possible
the president Trump was a Russian asset
an active Russian asset who's Andrew
McCabe again this was the former acting
FBI director these are not low ranking
people these are the heads of our
intelligence agencies these are our
Talking Heads in the media the people we
are supposed to trust at the most now
Matt Taibbi who I generally disagree
with over at Rolling Stone he once wrote
one of the worst profiles of Andrew
Breitbart
ever he weren't a terrible terrible
eulogy of and referees died but Matt
Taibbi has a piece today talking about
how this is the media's
where this is the media's WMD I think
that's an understatement
the media humiliated themselves our
intelligence agencies at least the
leaders of them people like James Comey
as we'll see and Andrew came humiliated
themselves here's Andrew McCabe
explaining the president Trump may
indeed have been a Russian asset I did
my job I've stood up to the obligations
of my office when presented with facts
we made hard decisions decisions that we
knew would be tough on the organization
would be tough on us personally look
what I've gone through as a result of
those decisions but we did them anyway
because we were committed to my
responsibilities and serving this
country do you still believe the
president could be a Russian asset I
think it's possible I think that's why
we started our investigation and I'm
really anxious to see where director
Muller concludes what the actual f I
don't remember when he said this on the
air I played it on the show the next day
and I said to myself what I mean I said
it openly what is what is he talking
about
how exactly is he up holding any
standard of intelligence behavior here
isn't the proper response I haven't seen
any evidence of that how is it it's
possible yes it's possible that he
descended from the moon it's possible
that President Trump is actually the
minion of the Martian the little Martian
from the Warner Brothers cartoons there
there are lots of things that are
possible but it is your job as the
former head of the FBI to maintain the
integrity of your institution that's not
what any of these people did and of
course then there are the people who had
a vested interest in this then there
were Democrats if Hillary Clinton who
legitimately said that President Trump
guided the Russians he provided them a
road map the Russians never could have
figured out something like facebook
without President Trump who has never
used a computer basically guiding them
around the interwebs the Russians in my
opinion and based on the Intel encounter
Intel people I've talked to could not
have known how best to weaponize that
information unless they had been guided
and here's a here's I by Americans
guided by Americans and guided by people
who had you know polling and date
equation which I gleaning Trump yes yes
I'm leanin Trump I think I think it's
pretty hard not to oh yeah of course
who's trump is Trump who stole the
election from
it wasn't that she was a garbage
candidate who lost because she ran a
garbage campaign to the worst candidate
in American history Trump I mean I know
that we've created this magical world in
which Trump was this world-beating
candidate president Trump had a tape
released on him a month before the
election in which he said that he was
grabbing women by the genitals and then
he beat Hillary Clinton that's how bad a
candidate she was that's why she lost
not because of the Rooskies and not
because president Trump was working with
Vladimir Putin hand in glove and that
and then this has dripped down to
legitimately every level of the
Democratic Party
this myth-making has dripped down to
Evert it's become the conventional
wisdom beta O'Rourke yesterday who will
jump on any object he could possibly
find and then somebody needs to start an
account on Twitter called bado jumps on
objects because that's pretty much what
he does at this point he just goes up to
tables he jumps on them he was up two
small children he jumps on them well
yesterday he jumped on an object and
then he suggests in front of a crowd
that President Trump sought to collude
with the Russians beyond the shadow of a
doubt he said this like legitimately
about two hours before William Barr
dropped his letter okay how exactly okay
so he says all this this and every
Democrat has basically echoed this maybe
president Trump will be impeached on
this maybe president Trump committed
treason
maybe president Trump was guilty the
entire goal of this was to create a
massive shadow over the first couple of
years of president Trump's presidency at
a very minimum time magazine you'll
recall ran a full cover in which it
showed the White House shading into the
Kremlin so halfway across the time
magazine cover
the White House suddenly becomes the
Kremlin because the Kremlin is owning
and operating at the White House now
here's the reality the Kremlin owned and
operated the media in the sense that the
media did exactly what Vladimir Putin
wants above Lattimore Putin wanted was
to interfere in the election and then
have the media run with whatever
narrative they felt was most conducive
to their point of view and tear the
country apart and they did it they did
it with ease now here's the thing it
wasn't that hard to avoid this error and
forget about being on the take
a strong stand in favor of the idea that
this was all a mockery or that this is
all nonsense
there was a very easy position available
to everyone right left and center the
easy position was I don't know that was
the easy position because nobody knew
right I didn't know Muller may have come
down yesterday or Friday he could have
come down with a report that said
precisely the reverse I didn't know you
didn't know nobody knew now there were
indicators that this report was not
going to be a bombshell
there were indicators that there were
members of the intelligence community
who hated President Trump there were
indicators that nobody had seriously
been indicted in the collusion scandal
for collusion
they'd been indicted for lying to the
FBI but you didn't even have to leap to
the conclusion that this was all some
sort of giant setup to simply say listen
we can wait for the evidence to come out
Bob Muller has a record as being a good
prosecutor and a decent man and there's
no reason to suspect that he is going to
come out and destroy president Trump
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about your second
Amendment rights attention to all
Patriots this is your last chance to win
one of the most popular in advanced
1911's on the market you see I've teamed
up with the US ECA to give you seven
chances to win
1234 bucks that is the exact amount you
need to buy this very special gun but it
all ends this week after Friday March
29th this gun will be gone so which 1911
are you winning remember there are there
the hints it's it's lightweight it's
easy to shoot making it one of most
popular 1911's to carry concealed it
boasts night sights g10 grips and comes
in a beautiful flat dark earth finish
you want to see for yourself just text
the word win - 87 - 2 - right now -
reveal this gun and instantly lock in
your seventh free chances to win it
law-abiding citizens should be protected
texts win - 87 - two - it is simple
quick 100 percent free but you need a
hurry because the incredible giveaway
ends this Friday as an extra bonus the
first 2,000 people to text in will also
be sent a free concealed carry guide
just for entering you should be a member
of the u.s. CCNA CCA anyway they have
fantastic resources so text the word win
- 87 - 2 - right now for the official
rules lock in your 7 entries and get
your free concealed carry guide now
before it is too late text win - 87 - G
- WI n - 87 - 2 - ok so as I say it was
not difficult to take a reasonable
position on this particular issue
now I understand President Trump was out
there saying that Bob Muller was corrupt
that the entire investigation was
corrupt that it was a witch hunt and all
of the rest and he didn't have to
believe that you also didn't have to
believe that the media that their
narrative the president Trump was a
Russian asset like Kevin Costner in no
way out you'd have to believe that
either you know you could have said why
don't we just wait and then the evidence
will come out now not to brag or
anything but this was the only
reasonable position in all of this okay
the truly reasonable position was I
don't know I said this to Bill Maher and
Bill Maher couldn't believe it you
actually think that Donald Trump collude
admirin yes
do you well I don't think he did it but
his you know his son did it his is the
people who when the evidence comes out
I'm happy to go for the indictments I'm
fine okay criminal activities criminal
acts what you see she didn't do but
wearing is to ignorance who have done it
I wait for the Muller indictments and
Craig come down and they target Trump
I'm happy to see him impeached or do I
need to see evidence what are you Muller
is the one who matters here now report
goes to the Deputy Attorney General and
if Trump puts Scott Baio in that
position
he can just throw it in the trash and if
he throws it in the trash or quashes the
muller investigation then yes
impeachment should be on the table okay
so I said all of this stuff and this was
a reasonable position that the left
could have taken but instead they
decided to get way out over their skis
Trump was definitely a Russian asset you
heard you heard Bill Maher say that and
on Friday night he said the same thing I
don't care what the Russian I don't care
what the report says this is the way
it's gonna go I don't care what the
report says in the end what matters is
that I believe my narrative and my
narrative suggests that President Trump
is guilty guilty guilty guilty guilty
okay all of this brings us to the actual
bar report so I'm going to read you the
entirety of the bar report why because
you should have access to all of the
information before us you shouldn't be
reading the media headlines you
shouldn't be listening to any of the
pundits what you should be doing is
listening to the actual words of the BI
report and I will stop and I will
explain what exactly the bar report says
so you know everything okay we are sill
awaiting the full bar release of as much
of the malla report as you can but here
is the letter that he sent to the heads
of the Judiciary Committee in the Senate
and in the house dear chairman Graham
chairman Naylor
ranking member Feinstein and ranking
member Collins as a supplement to the
notification provided on Friday March
22nd 2019 I am writing today to advise
you of the principled conclusions
reached by Special Counsel Robert S
Mulliken and to inform you about the
status of my initial review of the
report he has prepared section 1 the
special counsels report on Friday the
special counsel submitted to me a
confidential report explaining the
prosecution or declination decisions he
has reached as required by 28 CFR
section 620a --tz-- II this report is
entitled report on the investigation
into Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election although my review
is ongoing I believe that it is in the
public interest to describe the report
and to summarize the principled
conclusions reached by the special
counsel and the results of his
investigation the report explains that
the special counsel and his staff
thoroughly investigated allegations that
members of the presidential campaign of
Donald J Trump and others associated
with it
conspired with the Russian government in
its efforts to interfere in the 2016 US
presidential election or sought to
obstruct the related federal
investigations in the report the special
noted that in completing his
investigation he employed 19 lawyers who
were assisted by a team of approximately
40 FBI agents intelligence analysts
forensic accountants and other
professional staff the Special Counsel
issued more than 2,800 subpoenas
executed nearly 500 search warrants
obtained more than 230 orders for
communications records issued almost 50
orders authorizing use of pen registers
made 13 requests to foreign governments
for evidence and interviewed
approximately 500 witnesses that's
pretty damn thorough guys so you're
hearing one of the arguments you're
hearing from left is you know what we
need more investigations we need the
house to look into this the House
Judiciary Committee they can be trusted
Muller was bought and paid for guys
probably this is just William Barr and
Trump secretly manipulating behind the
scenes 2,800 subpoenas and 500 witnesses
pretty sure they talk to everybody the
Special Counsel obtained a number of
indictments and convictions of
individuals and entities in connection
with this investigation all of which
have been publicly disclosed during the
course of his investigation the special
counsel also referred several matters to
other offices for few for further action
the report does not recommend any
further indictments nor did the Special
Counsel obtain any sealed indictments
that have yet to be made public below I
summarize the principal conclusion set
out in the special counsels report drum
roll please section 2 Russian
interference in the 2016 US presidential
election the special counsels report is
divided into two parts Rights William
Bar the Attorney General the first
describes the results of the special
counsels investigation into Russia's
interference in the 2016 US presidential
election the report outlines the russian
effort to influence the election and
documents crimes committed by persons
associated with the russian government
in connection with those efforts the
report further explains that a primary
consideration for the special counsels
investigation was whether any Americans
including individuals associated with
the Trump campaign joined the Russian
conspiracies to influence the election
which would be a federal crime the
special counsels investigation did not
find that the Trump campaign or anyone
associated with it conspired or
coordinated with Russia in its efforts
to influence the 2016 US presidential
election period end of paragraph guys
that's a no on the collusion
a clear statement of no now are the
media accepting listen of course not the
media are suggesting that maybe bar is
shaping the results here maybe there's
something nefarious going on that's one
of my favorite arguments is that bar is
somehow lying about what Muller actually
turned into him I will remind you I will
remind you that Robert Muller forcefully
came out and denounced a BuzzFeed story
that lied about what the investigation
was going to find so he is not shy if it
turns out that Barr is lying we would
have known that already the report
continues as the report states the
investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government and its election interference
activities now the way that the left is
reading this is they are saying that if
the investigation did not establish it
then maybe there were some indicators
that maybe they were trying or something
like that okay here's the reality if Bob
Muller had been unsure about this
conclusion if he had thought that there
was evidence that could have gone either
way sufficient to sustain a prosecution
and Bob Muller would have written that
because that is what he wrote about
obstruction of justice but that is not
what he wrote when it came to Russian
collusion the special counsels
investigation determined that there were
two main Russian efforts to influence
the 2016 election the first involved
attempts by a Russian organization the
internet research agency the IRA to
conduct disinformation and social media
operations in the United States designed
to sow social discord eventually with
the aim of interfering with the election
as noted above the special counsel did
not find that any US person or Trump
campaign official or associate conspired
or knowingly conspire coordinated with
the IRA in its efforts although the
special counsel brought criminal charges
against a number of Russian nationals
and entities in connection with these
activities the second element involved
in the Russian government's efforts to
conduct computer hacking operations
designed to gather and disseminate
information to influence the election
this is the hack on John Podesta and the
DNC the special counsel found that
Russian government actors successfully
hacked into computers and obtained
emails from persons affiliated with the
Clinton campaign and Democratic Party
organizations and publicly disseminated
those materials through various
intermediaries including WikiLeaks based
on these activities the special counsel
brought criminal charges against a
number of Russian military officers for
conspiring to hack into computers in the
States for purposes of influencing the
election but as noted above the special
counsel did not find that the Trump
campaign or anyone associated with it
conspired or coordinated with the
Russian government in these efforts
despite multiple offers from Russian
affiliated individuals to assist the
Trump campaign that presumably would be
a reference to the June 2016 Trump Tower
meeting there's a footnote here it says
in assessing potential conspiracy
charges the special counsel also
considered whether members of the Trump
campaign coordinated with Russian
election interference activities the
special counsel defined coordination as
an agreement tacit or express between
the Trump campaign and the Russian
government on election interference in
other words there was no secret deal no
secret deal headline number one no
collusion just didn't exist no collusion
okay in one second we're gonna get to
the second issue
obstruction of justice and I'll explain
how the media are even now trying to fit
about this one because they simply can't
accept the L take the L guys it's pretty
obvious what you did here hey and a
second we'll get to that first you've
heard me talk about how ring is
reinventing home security with doorbells
cameras even an alarm you can install
yourself now they are reinventing the
neighborhood watch with a new app they
created it's called neighbors by ring
you remember the neighborhood watch it's
been around for a while I remember it
growing up it's still a big thing people
care about making their neighborhood
safer and it benefits everybody so ring
a company synonymous with reinventing
home security reinvented the
neighborhood watch they have something
called the neighbors app it's like the
new neighborhood watch on your phone
people taking stuff off porches trying
doorknobs late at night missing dogs the
neighbors app sends real-time
notifications to your phone whenever one
of your neighbors posts a heads-up about
something that's going on and it helps
keep you informed helps you keep watch
on your property on your stuff the
neighbors app by ring is completely free
anyone can join even if you don't own a
ring device I've looked through the
neighbors have and you're kind of
astounded to see the crime that's taking
place in your neighborhood and that
allows you sort of a heads up as to as
to how to keep an eye on a property I
saw one video actually this morning
somebody in my area is going around and
clipping gas pipes to steal gas from
people I mean it's just bizarro world
we're living in a world where you should
be aware of your surroundings and
wherever your neighborhood and that's
what the neighborhood app does you got
to check it out yourself the easiest way
to get to get it he's going to ring calm
slash Shapiro make your neighborhood
safer today with the neighbors
by ring again that's ring.com / shapiro
ring.com
/ apparel go check it out right now I
love all the ring products and this is a
great new app neighbors app from ring
comm so that should pair you really have
to be a member of ring to get the app
ring comm / Shapiro ok so the report
from William bar continues on
obstruction of justice
the reports second part addresses a
number of actions by the president most
of which have been the subject of public
reporting that the special counsel
investigated as potentially raising
obstruction of justice concerns after
making a thorough factual investigation
into these matters the Special Counsel
considered whether to evaluate the
conduct under department standards
governing prosecution and declination
decisions but ultimately determined not
to make a traditional prosecutorial
judgment the special counsel therefore
did not draw a conclusion one way or the
other as to whether the examines conduct
constituted obstruction so the special
counsel did not say we declined to
prosecute or he should be prosecuted
instead he said listen I don't know I
don't know it's all public if this is
impeachable stuff go for it if not then
not but it's hard to imagine there's an
impeachment for obstruction when there's
no underlying crime what exactly would
Trump have been trying to obstruct again
one of my contentions the entire time is
that Bob Millar was not obstructed by
President Trump James Comey admitted
that the investigation was not
obstructed by President Trump Trump
tweeting random crap out there does not
constitute obstruction we've covered
this at length on the show instead says
bar for each of the relevant actions
investigated the report sets out
evidence on both sides of the question
and leaves unresolved what unresolved
with the special counsel views as
difficult issues of law in fact
concerning whether the president's
actions and intent could be viewed as
obstruction the special counsel states
that quote while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him and
this is the line that the media have
been focusing in on oh it doesn't
exonerate him it doesn't exonerate him
so that means that even if he didn't
commit a crime maybe he's guilty of
something okay now here's the reality we
all know what President Trump did here
President Trump put pressure publicly on
the Moller investigation but behind
closed doors he didn't actually stop
anything having to do with the model
investigation him fulminating on twitter
does not amount to obstruction him
telling people internally that he'd like
to fire bob muller does not it does not
amount to obstruction him talking about
how he'd like this investigation to end
him talking about how he fired James
because he was ticked off the whole
thing none of that amounts to
obstruction so that is controversial but
it is not controversial from a legal
point of view if mo are thought that
this was an open-and-shut obstruction
case then he would presumably have
recommended charging for obstruction and
a bunch of people on the Left saying
well you can't charge a president with
obstruction that's what he's really
saying that if he weren't president he'd
be charging him with obstruction that's
not what Barr says well Barr says is
that the report does not conclude that
the president committed a crime it
doesn't exonerate him because you can't
exonerate in a case of sort of public
view what's hilarious about all of this
is people saying well you know the
president shouldn't be exonerated
because obstruction of justice I mean
that even amounts to the president not
wanting to talk to Muller know that's
called like a normal legal defense as a
lawyer the first rule is shut your
client up I've been saying this about
Rudy Giuliani since the very beginning
dude get your guy to shut up the special
counsels decision to describe the facts
of his obstruction investigation without
reaching any legal conclusions leads it
to the Attorney General to determine
whether the conduct described in the
report constitutes a crime this is the
normal way things worked now people are
saying oh well William Barr stepped in
and shut down the possibility of an
investigation shut down the possibility
of a charge here you know why cuz that's
the do Jay's job you know what you're
not supposed to do is what James Comey
did with Hillary Clinton what he should
have done is what Muller did here he
should have said here are all the facts
laying him out now it's up to you
Loretta Lynch and if you want to shut
this thing down that's on your head well
the same thing happened here from Muller
over the course of the investigation the
special counsel's office engaged in
discussions with certain Department
officials regarding many of the legal
and factual matters at issue in the
special counsels obstruction
investigation after reviewing the
special counsels final report on these
issues consulting with Department
officials including the office of legal
counsel and applying the principles of
federal prosecution that guide our
charging decisions Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein and I have
concluded that the evidence developed
during the special counsels
investigation is not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense
now remember this is Rosen Stein going
along with the Shu president Trump's
been ripping on Rosenstein so as the
implication here that both bar and
Rosenstein are compromised as you'll see
the media say yes our determination was
made without regard to and is not based
on the constitutional considerations
that surround the indictment
criminal prosecution of a sitting
president in other words it has nothing
to do with he's the president so he
can't some struck justice this is just
not obstruction of justice is what Barr
is saying in making this determination
we note we noted that the Special
Counsel recognized that the evidence
does not establish that the president
was involved in an underlying crime
related to rush an election interference
so hard to obstruct an investigation
into a crime that doesn't exist and that
while not determinative the absence of
such evidence bears upon the president's
intent with respect to obstruction
generally speaking to obtain and sustain
an obstruction conviction the government
would need to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that a person acting with corrupt
intent intent is an element of the crime
and obstruction engaged in obstructive
conduct with a sufficient nexus to a
pending or contemplated proceeding right
that is the state of the law I've
described it multiple times on the show
and cataloging the president's actions
many of which took place in public view
the report identifies no actions that in
our judgment constitute obstructive
conduct had a nexus to a pending or
contemplated proceeding and were done
with corrupt intends each of which under
the department's principles of federal
prosecution
guiding charging decisions would need to
be proven beyond a reasonable doubt to
establish an obstruction of justice
offense in other words President Trump
says a lot of crap
that's what that that's the short
version Trump says a lot of crap and
because he says a lot of crap we can't
just say he's exonerated on this but we
also are not going to charge him for
saying a lot of crap because saying a
lot of crap it ain't a crime okay final
section of this report from William Barr
the status of the department's review
the relevant regulations contemplate
that the special counsels report will be
a confidential report to the Attorney
General as I have previously stated
however I'm mindful of the public
interest in this matter for that reason
my goal and intent is to release as much
of the special counsels report as I can
consistent with applicable law
regulations and departmental policies
based on my discussions with the special
counsel in my initial review it is
apparent that the report contains
material that is or could be subject to
Federal Rule of Criminal Procedure 6e
which imposes restrictions on the use
and disclosure of information relating
to matters occurring before a grand jury
rule 6 e generally limits disclosure of
certain grand jury information in a
criminal investigation and prosecution
disclosure of 60 material beyond the
strict limits set forth in the rule is a
crime in certain circumstances in other
words that can't just PDF the whole
report and put it online that's a
violation of the basic rules of Criminal
Procedure this restriction protects
the integrity of grand jury proceedings
and ensures that the unique and
invaluable investigative powers of a
grand jury are used strictly for their
intended criminal justice function given
these restrictions the schedule for
processing the report depends in part on
how quickly the department can identify
the 6e material that by law cannot be
made public I have requested the
assistance of the special counsel in
identifying all sixty information
contained in the report as quickly as
possible in other words he's gonna ask
Bob Muller what he's allowed to reveal
so again this is not Barr trying to
redact crap who can't read ACK
separately I also must identify any
information that could impact other
ongoing matters including those that the
special counsel has referred to other
offices as soon as that process is
complete I will be in a position to move
forward expeditiously in determining
what can be released in light of
applicable law regulations and
departmental policies as I observed in
my initial notification the special
counsel regulations provide that the
Attorney General may determine the
public release of notifications to your
respective committees would be in the
public interest I have so determines and
I will disclose this letter to the
public after delivering it Hugh
sincerely William bar attorney general
okay that's the entirety of the letter
so you have now heard it from beginning
to end so now you can make up your own
mind on what the media are telling you
about all of this suffice it to say my
belief is that the media are
deliberately attempting to shade this
report because they humiliated
themselves there's not just egg on their
face they went to a chicken farm they
took every egg in the chicken farm they
shattered it over their own head the egg
covers them to the extent that they are
now up to their nose in egg and yet the
media are gonna continue to pretend that
this was all done on the up-and-up that
they handled this exactly right
we're gonna get the president from some
reaction to all of this in just a second
plus I do want to discuss the blowback
that should take place not just in the
media not just people who should sit
down for a while and have a big think on
what exactly they did here but also
there should be blowback in terms of
presumably members of the government if
sufficient evidence can be shown that
this was done with bad faith but it
wasn't just stupidity and confirmation
bias now my tendency is to believe that
members of the government like everyone
else is just dumb that's stupidity
governs and that everybody who was
involved in this thing got caught up in
the wave of emotion they didn't like
president Trump and then they let that
confirmation bias shape the nature of
this investigation is that criminal
doubt it but does
demonstrate once again that our
intelligence agents are humans made up
of humans and subject to the same flaws
and failings as other humans you bet
but here's video the same people who are
complaining yesterday about Bob Muller
being a corrupt guy I don't think you
can trust them on these issues either
Bob Muller did what he was supposed to
do here's he can't trust the media who
said that it was a foregone conclusion
the President Trump was going to jail
and the people who are saying for years
that Bob Miller was a corrupt person who
was simply going to get president Trump
using the powers of his office both of
those things have proved not to be true
okay we're gonna get the president
Trump's reaction to all this which was
indeed hysterically funny we'll get to
all that in just a second first you have
to go over to Daley wire calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to Daley we're calm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live and two additional hours of this
show in the afternoon this afternoon I'm
actually off have to have a quick
medical thing done but if you go check
out Daley wire comm you get two extra
live hours of the show every day you get
the show on demand commercial free so
many great things plus when you get the
annual subscription for $99 here you get
this the very greatest and beverage
vessels he left his steers Hut or cold
tumbler these vessels are all over the
country I mean tens of thousands of them
are all over the United States last
night there's actually breaking news
that they were creating a flood warning
across the United States in the wake of
buyers letter this leftist here's how to
quote mug people didn't know is just
like flowing right at I mean people were
losing their hardwood floors it was
crazy but the good news is that the mugs
work really well so go check them out he
left his chairs hot or cold tumbler
check that out you get that with your
annual subscription I will also remind
you that my book the right side of
history is still unsay lever e where
it's still the number one nonfiction
book on Amazon it has been for nearly a
week it is still the number one
nonfiction book new nonfiction book on
Barnes & Noble so please help keep it
going we really appreciate it
and it's it's I think it's an important
book so so go check that out right now
also check us out at YouTube or iTunes
we have great new Sunday specials coming
out those become Saturday specials when
you are a subscriber we are the fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
you
all righty so president Trump reacts to
all of this and I have to say this was
the best Trump ever I mean this is like
high this is grade A plus plus Trump so
yesterday yesterday morning I wake up
and I noticed that President Trump has
tweeted and he hasn't tweeted for a
couple of days and I thought oh here we
go what had he tweeted you've heard good
morning
have a great day that's what he tweeted
and the media lost their poop they went
totally crazy relook home what does this
mean well this means he's a cruel evil
man people will die cory booker started
running around screaming about how
children were going to die and it was it
was just great and everybody's going
crazy over him saying good morning have
a great day
it was just I mean that is some
high-level drollery it's it's it's
spectacular then later in the day he
tweeted this out he tweeted make America
great again he tweeted that out it was
like 1 minute later so have a great day
and make America great again everybody's
like the crashing scene brothers or
their heads are exploding the pod bros
like oh my god is the worst he said
America is gonna be great and also have
a great day
obviously nefarious things are afoot and
then later in the day after the bar
report drops he writes no collusion no
obstruction complete and total
exoneration Keep America great now
technically he is correct of course
about no collusion on no obstruction he
is correct as well complete and total is
on eration not totally correct simply
because the Mulla report didn't say that
they would exonerate on obstruction but
it is very difficult to exonerate on
obstruction in a case where the
president has publicly talked about how
much he hates an investigation yeah you
can't really exonerate on that basis but
you can say not enough material to
charge which is a difference in American
law the President Trump was all that and
then president from finally speaks to
the press late yesterday afternoon and
he says you know I love America this
place unbelievable I just want to tell
you
that America is the greatest place on
earth the greatest place on earth thank
you very much and look the dudes been
put under the knife for two years on
this nonsense two years and I know
listen I know people in the Trump
administration who were interviewed by
the Muller folks I know people who had
to how boyar up on the basis of this who
were put through long long hearings on
all of this and it turned out to be
nothing and stupidity for the most part
and not for the most part just
ultimately just stupidity yes they get
to take a victory lap today
now Politico I have it's just amazing
political response to this with this
headline you ready after the nearly two
year investigation found no collusion or
clear obstruction of justice Trump and
his aides took little interest in
healing or national unity really so if I
accuse you of being a traitor for two
years and then it turns out that you are
not a traitor
the headline is gonna be that you're mad
about it that's the headline really a
president Trump wasn't done he said
listen this is an illegal takedown that
failed now here's where we get into the
question of what happens next there's
been some talk on the right about we
should go after and prosecute people who
were members of the FBI well then we
have to look at the criminal standards
the same way we did for President Trump
did they commit a crime was it a crime
for the FBI to get out over its skis was
it a crime for them to investigate
without convicting people for not
committing crimes in other words was an
investigation that was founded on flimsy
rumors is that criminal in and of itself
should people go to jail for that sort
of thing or was an investigation that
was founded on rumors that had to be
taken seriously at least at the time and
then it sort of grew based on the
stupidity and confirmation bias of
people who didn't like President Trump
is any of that criminal and if it's not
criminal then maybe this speaks to what
kind of power the intelligence agencies
should have overall because they are
staffed with human beings
confirmation bias very dangerous drug
and that is particularly true in the
government has enormous power here as
president Trump though saying that the
the investigation was an illegal
takedown that failed it was a complete
and total exoneration
it's a shame that our country had to go
through this to be honest it's a shame
that your president has had to go
through this four before I even got
elected it began and it began illegally
and hopefully somebody's gonna look at
the other side this was an illegal
takedown that failed okay so we will
find out whether it was an illegal
takedown that failed again I think it's
easy to jump the track here and suggest
that what needs to happen now is an
investigation into fusion GPS that may
be fusion gps should be prosecuted for
leaking material to the FBI it's the
FBI's job to check out the material if
you make a police report and that police
report is based on evidence that is not
put out there necessarily falsely but
it's just rumor mongering it is the
police's report it's the police's job to
differentiate between false and truth
truthfully and truthfulness that the
people who obviously blew this are the
members of the FBI and the members of
the media yeah again I think Apple
research being turned over to the FBI
and the DOJ I'm not sure that's quite
the same thing but again I'd like to
investigate the legal issues and take a
look at that before I make a final
conclusion I don't withhold judgment
meanwhile the leftist reaction to this
is absolute disbelief
I mean legitimate disbelief they cannot
believe they thought for sure this was
Robert Butler was the second coming he
was gonna descend from heaven and he was
going to tap president Trump on the
shoulder and president Trump was going
to disappear as though Thanos had
snapped his fingers he's just gonna turn
into a bowl of ash that didn't happen
and the Democrats were having none of it
here was Sheila jackson-lee
saying that she simply doesn't accept
the finding so I mean that's important
because obviously we need Sheila
jackson-lee to accept the findings
because nothing do you believe Robert
Muller when he writes that there was no
collusion I mean do you accept that
conclusion I think what I accept is that
Robert Muller did a very thorough job
and he has made the assessment that
there was no collusion again that is not
a legal term it's conspiracy but his
decision was based on a whole number of
factors and investigations and what I am
saying
we in the Judiciary Committee want to
review those documents okay so this is
going to be the Democratic take is we
don't believe barbar is now the obstacle
so Muller probably said there was
collusion but barb is the one who shut
it down now
obviously that is untrue obviously if
Muller felt that he was being big-footed
here he would say something about it he
did when BuzzFeed tried to do the same
thing but this is the new going theory
so the Democrats are now shifting the
goalposts the goal posts are now that it
is not necessary that he was involved in
collusion maybe it was obstruction and
also we're not gonna go with the
findings of the Mullen report now we
want to see the underlying materials so
Tom Perez the head of the DNC he says
the real question is is he compromised
we know he's not we just got the report
dude but I guess they're still gonna run
with this nonsense we know in addition
to the fact that the Russians tried to
meddle they didn't meddle in our
investigation we know that his campaign
managers deputy campaign manager his his
lawyer Papadopoulos stone all of these
people were having contact and so the
question for me that remains is was he
compromised why did he say that he
believes Putin over the intelligence
community why did he talk about leaving
NATO things that put our national
security at jeopardy why doesn't he
release his tax returns why were they so
hell-bent on getting that Trump Tower in
Moscow okay all of this conspiracy
theory garbage is just that conspiracy
theory garbage we all know why President
Trump said what he said about Vladimir
Putin two things he was offended by the
entire Russian investigation and also he
liked anybody who complements him end of
story
I've been saying that for legitimately
years at this point this is not a giant
secret but the media are not gonna let
go of this the Democrats are not gonna
let go of this they're going to suggest
that now Muller must have been
compromised or maybe they would have
drawn a different conclusion if they saw
the underlying materials here's Maxine
Waters who is just not a smart human
being suggesting on joy Reid's show that
it's not over it's not over guys it's
not over I mean that she's basically
doing the routine from Dreamgirls I'm
telling you I'm not going nothing no no
no no no they're gonna drag her away
screaming here is Maxine Waters this is
not the end of anything this is the well
it's the end of the report
the investigation by Muller but those of
us who chair these committees have a
responsibility to continue with our
oversight because there's so much that
needs to be you know taking a look at at
this point and so it's it's not the end
of everything oh it's not the end of
everything oh good ok so I'm glad you
guys are gonna keep doing this for the
next couple of years because you lied
you're base that's the problem here you
guys went over your skis and you lied to
your base you said your base that he was
gonna leave he's gonna be impeached
based on the Russian collusion stuff
they were out there worshipping Muller
and it turns out that Muller did not
give them what they wanted and now
Muller will be thrown in the garbage can
so the leftist reaction again has been
that maybe there's a cover-up my
favorite that the best response came
courtesy of James Comey you'll recall
that self-aggrandizing TWRP Comey the
former head of the FBI who was just
incompetent at his job in every possible
way and then President Trump fired him
and then he suggested without evidence
that President Trump was somehow
basically responsible for Russian
collusion he took a picture of himself I
kid you not in the woods hick went to
the woods and took a picture of himself
I guess on the moon of Endor and just
staring up into the trees with the
caption so many questions yeah you know
what we do have some questions James we
do have some questions like why was this
investigation initiated in the first
place was it done so on a solid basis
was it continued on the basis of new
additional evidence that was
corroborating or was this whole thing
basically just a bunch of people who
didn't like Trump who decided that they
were going to continue an investigation
into a nonsense charge from the very
beginning is that really what was going
on here and we'll find all of that out
we'll find out whether it's criminal
they're gonna be questions asked about
this as well there should be there
should be questions asked about this are
there criminal charges as they say I
don't know I'm withhold evidence on that
but come on come on
the leftist reaction has been utter
hysteria joy Reid on MSNBC she said well
you know maybe it's a cover-up maybe
it's a cover-up maybe Barr is just
covering it up the fact that this
investigation takes place with an
injustice Department which Donald Trump
essentially controls and that he got rid
of the problem Jeff Sessions who the one
decent thing that he did was just recuse
himself
this guy is not recused it feels like
the seeds of a cover-up are here Oh
without any you're not more speculation
we'll probably fix it Media keep going
with this more rampant stupid
speculation will probably shore up your
reputations now that they are in
absolute flames you douse yourself in
gasoline and lit a match that's what you
did my favorite are the tweets from the
people in Hollywood who again know
nothing about politics and so are more
hysterical than anyone these are that
these are the people in the in the Jim
Jones media cults were legitimately
drinking the kool-aid people like Bette
Midler who tweeted this out Muller's
report finds no evidence showing Trump's
team collusion with Russia but stopped
short of exonerating trump on
obstruction of justice
knowing trump he probably tried to do
exactly that two more years of chaos
race baiting grifters con artists shame
and fear sad knowing Trump he probably
tried to do exactly that really do you
know Trump or were you saying for years
that he colluded with the Russians how
about Rob Reiner whose last good movie
was Princess Bride the fight for our
democracy is about to intensify the GOP
cult is lining up behind a criminal
autocrat is there any employee like
where's the criminality here have you
have you shown some proof yet wait that
would be that'd be good
how about how about some of that you got
Jon Cryer from Two and a Half Men who is
tweeting out this is why Trump appointed
parkas to cover up coverage and then
there's George Takei owned by if William
Byers summarized Romeo and Juliet he'd
probably say that Romeo murdered
Juliet's cousin was banished for it and
is now dead let's wait to hear the full
story yeah it's probably that bar is
just blowing the findings even those
gonna release the vast majority of this
stuff the best the best reaction that
was reserved for media watchdog brian
Stelter over at CNN now I've been on
Brian's show seems like a nice guy but
this is crazy stuff here's brian Stelter
suggesting you know what maybe we
shouldn't have done so much speculation
but speculation has value to guys it
really does there is a big difference
there is a big difference between news
and opinion and I realize it can be hard
to turn out all the noise and just tune
into the news these days but if I had to
pick speculation or solid reporting I
would pick solid reporting in a second I
bet you would too reporting is what adds
the most value finding out something new
putting out new information into the
world is the best feeling in journalism
it's the greatest value add
that's what hundreds of journalists have
been doing trying to solve pieces of
this Trump Russia puzzle but here's the
thing speculation actually has value to
it helps open our eyes helps open our
minds to what's possible okay so it's a
speculation helps us that's what it is
it's just mind expanding guys that's all
we were trying to do was expand minds
when her around KY runs for two years
about how Trump was lying about Russian
collusion and then in parentheses
no collusion in parentheses hasn't been
proved now let's see
CNN run the chyron that says CNN for two
years ran with collusion it never
happened in parentheses man they
humiliated themselves and they deserve
every bit of the blowback they are going
to get from the American public and and
from other members of the media and from
Ephraim I mean it's just what a botched
job what a botched job for two years
full full craziness okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like there's a
movie that was nominated for was it not
me for Best Picture on things I think
it's been done for Best Screenplay
it was isn't it won Best Foreign picture
and the movies called Cold War it's
basically about a love affair in in Cold
War Poland it's it's a it is a good
movie the the basic notion of the movie
is that there is this guy who is the
head of the music program in Poland he
falls in love with one of the women who
who is part of his act he defects to the
west she follows him and then it's about
their romance in the middle of the Cold
War the underlying unease with them film
of course is really not about their
relationship it's about the fact that
whenever they're in the West their
relationship seems to fall apart
whenever they are whenever they're in
the East meaning in Poland when they're
when they're on the other side of the
Berlin wall then their relationship
seems to solidify but that is simply
because of the pressures on them and so
this it's kind of fascinating that way
here is a little bit of the preview it
is a foreign language films I'm not
gonna play too much of it
[Music]
so she's a jazz singer he is a jazz
arranger and it is it's an effective
movie it's an effective film it has some
things to say about the nature of
communism and it also has something to
say about the nature of human
relationships and whether a relationship
is really solid if it can't maintain
itself when there aren't the outside
pressures on it okay time for some
things that I hated so many things that
I ate today many a thing that I hate so
thing number one that I hate in the
aftermath of the New Zealand shootings
is we already know there was a move to
ban guns essentially in in New Zealand
there was going to be a full-scale
attempt to see semi-automatic weapons
but that was not the only violation of
freedoms in New Zealand this is why I
need your responses to tragedy are
usually a bad idea according to USA
Today the chief censor of New Zealand
now first of all why do they have a
chief censor in New Zealand does that
seem like a free speech thing to you to
have a chief sight how would you like to
have a chief censor in the United States
that's not like a good idea or a bad
idea it's funny I'm not saying members
the left going in New Zealand they can
just ban speech why can't we do that
here I mean they take shooting seriously
over there they just ban things it's so
funny the same people on the Left who
say you know when it comes to the Second
Amendment yeah why look at New Zealand
it's just great they can summarily ban
guns not seeing the same sort of
reaction when it comes to banning speech
their chief censor has been the 74 page
manifesto written and released by the
evil piece-of-crap who slaughtered 50
people at two mosques in the city of
Christchurch the ban was issued on
Saturday it means that anyone caught
with the document on their computer
could face up to 10 years in prison
anyone caught sending it could face 14
years in prison now I've encouraged
people not to read the manifesto because
I don't think that this guy's evil ideas
should spread and I've encouraged people
not to use his name do I think somebody
should go to jail for 10 years for
having the document on their computer I
mean he'll I've got the document on my
computer because I had to read it to
cover it for the show I have the
document on my computer because I had to
actually read it so that I knew what
exactly the media were saying about it
and whether it was true or not ten years
in prison for having a document on your
computer how in the world is that a
proper response to an act of evil
amazing amazing stuff I mean my goodness
turns out the same people who want to
ban guns in some cases are fine with
banning speech that is that is insane
that is insane it's a it's an evil
manifesto filled with evil should you
ban it of course you shouldn't ban it
that's crazy okay other things that I
hate so I would just like to point out
that our moral betters in Hollywood are
not actually our moral betters a lot of
them are kind of garbage people one of
these garbage people is Barbra Streisand
so Barbra Streisand was talking with a
British newspaper The Times of London
and she was asked about Wade Robson and
James safe Chuck who are the two main
subjects of the HBO documentary and even
leaving Neverland about Michael Jackson
allegedly molesting children she said
quote that they were thrilled to be
there as children
and whatever happened to them quote
unquote didn't kill them she said she
believes the victims claims but felt bad
for both them and Jackson adding quote
that Jackson's sexual needs were his
sexual leads and that the blame should
lie with the boys as parents now I do
not disagree that the boys as parents
carry a hell of a lot of blame but what
the actual really that they were happy
to be there they were thrilled to be
there and his sexual needs were his
sexual needs
now she was good friends with with
Michael Jackson this just goes to show
you once again confirmation bias
wow what a hell of a drug you start to
just you start to basically slough off
actual child molestation she said you
can say molested but those children as
you heard they were thrilled to be there
they both married they both have
children so it didn't kill them she said
I feel bad for the children I feel bad
for him I play I guess I blame the
parents who would allow their children
to sleep with him why would Michael need
those little children dressed like him
and in the shoes and in the dancing in
the Hat
man how she continues to have a job
after that now as I've said I'm not in
favor of people losing their jobs for
old things they say old things that they
say but if you're buying a Barbra
Streisand album after she says something
like that I gotta say I'm not sure
what's going through your head pretty
well but don't worry the people in
Hollywood those are the people who
should trust with with deciding our
morals
these are the folks who really I think
ought to lean on heavily when it comes
to making our moral decisions final
thing that I hate so Ilhan Omar spoke at
a care event an event sponsored by the
Council on american-islamic relations an
unindicted co-conspirator in the Holy
Land Foundation terror trial and at this
event again sponsored by a group that
has connections to terrorism she
suggested that she didn't care about the
pro-israel protestors outside she didn't
care what they had to say what they
really had to say is stop being an
anti-semite of course you doesn't care
what they have to say because she's an
anti-semite I know I know many of them
drove miles to get here spent a lot of
energy and resources and money to
purchase the signs that they have but I
don't think any of them realize that
people like myself and many of the
people in this room can care less about
what they have to say yeah we know that
we know you don't care when it comes to
anti-semitism you don't care and the
Democratic Party went along with that so
that is not a shock in any way shape or
form okay well normally would be back
for two hours later today we do have a
guest host later today so if you want
more material go check that out later
today I will be back here with you
tomorrow we will break down everything
we'll have three hours long should go
subscribe please pick up a copy of my
book the right side of history I think
it's an important book I think it's it's
got some depth to it if I do say so
myself so go check that out right now it
is surging up the bestseller charts
still the number one nonfiction
best-selling book in the United States
according to both Amazon and Barnes &
Noble so go check that out right now we
really appreciate it
and we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show well robert
muller and donald trump agree there is
no collusion we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Klavan show I'm Andrew Clayton